after Decades of colonialism and
neo-colonialism it was France's
withdrawal from Mali last year and
Burkina Faso this year which
emphatically confirmed the shifting
geopolitics in central Africa French
troops were forced to leave and the
military Junta in each of those
countries opted for a new alliance with
Russia in the form of the mercenary
Wagner group president macron openly
admits that mistakes were made in Mali
and his four-nation tour of central
Africa will sell a more Cooperative
Vision with host Nations cultural
scientific and educational Partnerships
and military bases where the French
troops operators Partners rather than
commanders
the reorganization is not meant to be a
retreat or disengagement it will
material us through an africanization or
Mutual operation of these big bases
is the former head of the French
military mission of the United Nations
he agrees the importance of France
staying militarily engaged in the region
we have to have small teams
for example to help this African country
this is exactly the case in Niger for
example where the parliament asks the
French forces to stay and to fight in
support of the Nigerian forces that's
probably the case also in Chad where
we've got a big air base in central
Africa itself some see the rejection of
French influences understandable but
nonetheless alarming and irrational yes
there is anger about European
neocolonialism however the alliance is
being offered by China and Russia bring
their own issues the Western world has
abused its position is its position of
domination it is very difficult period
in our history because
uh when people are not rational anymore
like now they just have one one goal we
want to get rid of France we want to
give to get rid of the old system
actually and and not realizing that uh
what is ahead is not probably better
than what they are running away from
president macron embarks on this to
admitting that for too long France has
regarded Africa with what he described
as the logic of rent his new vision is
to offer a more mutually beneficial
partnership but he faces an uphill task
to turn around that wave of anti-french
sentiment
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Paris